hey BuzzFeed I'm Jackson when from China
and today I'm gonna answer 30 questions
in 30 seconds I'm thirty minutes of
three minutes
oh my god let's go put some a long while
[Music]
a well I mean well you know honey I love
you a mobile with signal to comment
manages to bring me back my manager
regrets don't ever eat sugar mix I'm
Jackson we're from China next
[Music]
welcome as a girl I don't like long hair
cut it short good question
next yes oh my god that was ambition
passion oh my god Thanks
ah work hard play hard when I was in
primary school I mean my parents got a
middle school I changed my email to her
name yeah please delete this what oh my
goodness Oh Chinese mixed no of course
like ten minutes what do you think
mint chocolate mixed I don't have a
password Oh what I'm not gonna tell you
five my parents baby doctor of course I
am being my best buddy every twice a
week okay next no spicy we're next
I'm allergic geez Oh
Oh mom or dad
[Music]
mom but I love you dad I did it right I
can't even do like sixty questions Thank
You BuzzFeed
[Music]